نعم عثمان الوضع يزداد صعوبه تحديدا مع
ساعات الليل في مدينه خان يونس مع اشتداد
وتيره الاشتباكات العنيفه في محيط منطقه
البلد في مدينه خان يونس بالاضافه الى حي
الامل ومنطقه المشروع شمال المدينه سبق
اشتباكات عنيفه وضاره بين المقاومه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
تكثيف الغارات والقصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي
ويسمع بحسب افادات شهود عيان داخل مجمع
ناصر الطبي ذوي اشتباكات عنيفه بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي تحاصر هذا المجمع الرئيسي
والذي يعد ثاني اكبر مستشفيات قطاع غزه
لليوم السادس على التوالي وسط ظروف
انسانيه صعبه ليس فقط على صعيد الكادر
الطبي والمرضى والجرحى داخل المستشفى بل
ايضا عن نتحدث عن الاف النازحين الذين
لجوا الى داخل اسوار المستشفى هربا من
نيران القصف والغارات الاسرائيليه التي
طالت مراكز الاواء المحيطه به او حتى
منازلهم التي كانوا يقطنون بها وهناك نقص
حاد في المواد التموينيه والغذائيه
بالاضافه الى المياه الصالحه للشرب بعد
الاستهداف الاسرائيلي المتعمد لخزانات
المياه في مستشفى ناصر ما ادى الى تلفها
وتسرب المياه ايضا الى قسم العنايه
المركزه الذي نفذت داخله ادويه التخدير
بالاضافه الى ادويه رئيسيه ومهمه لانقاذ
حياه المصابين بجروح خطيره في هذا القسم
الى جانب الحصار المضروب ايضا على مستشفى
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ومركز الاسعاف
والطوارئ الاوضاع صعبه جدا حتى ان سيارات
الاسعاف والمواطنين لا يستطيعون الوصول
الى بعض المناطق لانتشال جثامين الشهداء
وايضا اجلاء العائلات المحاصره بالاضافه
الى انقاذ حياه المصابين ايه هذا اليوم
بحسب افادات شهود عيان ايضا فان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وقناص الجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اقدم على اغتيال شابين
فلسطينيين في محيط مسجد الشافعي فجاء شاب
ثالث لانقاذ وانتشال جثامين الشهيدين الا
ان قناص اسرائيلي ايه استهدفه بعيار ناري
في الراس فاردا شهيدا الى جانب الشهيدين
الاخرين وحتى هذه اللحظه لم يتمكن احد من
الوصول الى تلك المنطقه لانتشال جثامين
الشهداء الثلاثه بالاضافه الى الاوضاع
الانسانيه الصعبه لمن فضل الب قاء داخل
المدينه تحديدا على صعيد الاطفال والنساء
وكبار السن واصحاب الامراض المزمنه حيث لا
تتوفر الادويه ولا حتى مياه الشرب ولا
الطعام لهم وسط مناشدات كبيره للصليب
الاحمر للامم المتحده بضروره فتح ممر
انساني لادخال المواد الغذائيه والتموين
وايضا المياه بالاضافه الى
انقاذ مستشفى ناصر ومستشفى الامل وادخال
الامدادات والمستلزمات الطبيه والادويه
ايضا المدفعيه الاسرائيلي حتى منطقه
المواص التي يدعي جيش الاحتلال انها امنه
استهدفت منطقه الملالحه غرب مدينه خانيونس
وادت الى ارتقاء اربعه من الشهداء
بالاضافه الى وصول عدد من الاصابات الى
النقطه الطبيه التي اطر الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني الى تاسيسها على ساحل البحر
ونقل الشهداء والجرحى منها الى مستشفى ابو
يوسف النجار في مدينه رفح اي الاوضاع هنا
في مدينه رفح لا تقل سوءا عن مدينه
خانيونس مع تكدس مئات الالاف من اللاجئين
فالقصف الاسرائيلي الذي يلاحق النازحين
هنا في مدينه خان يونس صاحبه سوء الاحوال
الجويه القاسيه التي زادت من معاناه
وماساه النازحين في مدينه رفح